it's great to have you with us we're
going to be as you can see graphing
absolute value functions today we're
getting straight back into this idea of
graphing techniques until the end of
next week and I thought I should start I
always like to begin this way by giving
you a justification for why we care
about this because we're going to get
stuck into the weeds pretty quickly and
so I want to make sure we just have a
kind of top-line view wild why does it
matter to us why absolute value
functions a thing that we say you need
to learn about and we're going to assess
you on your ability to do these things
so this is just an example from my life
that I've just pulled up this is from
this week I'm not I'm not especially fit
I don't have a very athletic physique
but I try my best and you know coverts
giving us all excuse to try and get out
and about so what are you looking at
here Wow someone's microphone just went
bananas and started screaming I don't
know whose it is sorry I can see most
people are on mute though so it's
someone I can't see in the background so
if you can make sure your mute that'd be
really helpful thank you okay I'm gonna
keep going so this is a run I went on on
Monday evening on Monday night and I
want you to in particular have a look at
this feature that was highlighted on the
left hand side which is elevation okay
so like most of you do I live in the
hills area which is really great for
writing and terrible for running so you
guys have gone up and I've gone down and
my GPS is tracked that I've gone through
94 meters of what they say is elevation
now what does that mean well that's
about going up hills and down hills and
then taking the sum of all of that now
if you look more closely and drill into
where did the red of the app on my phone
get all this information from if you
have a look over here on the right hand
side you can see for every kilometer
that I've gone it's tracked how far I've
gone up how far I've gone down and you
can see the down elevations over there
in the right hand side in negative right
so you've got you can see it's some of
the fastest parts that I ran kilometer
five kilometer six they are in going
down a hill so no surprises that I can
run faster there right so what the
absolute value is doing here is saying
okay I know what you really mean is your
total up and total
so instead of adding up all these
numbers together and you're going to get
something close to zero because i
roughly entered where i started i might
actually want to know the total change
and this is something that we looked at
with integration right we're answering
the same question here all what is the
total amount of change whether it's a
distance or a number of people who've
gotten sick because of covert or
whatever it is right so this is why we
care about absolute value when change is
the thing that we're interested in and
the direction in which you change
matters less so this is just one
instance of that can we
knuckle down into the mathematics of
this well when we think about absolute
value there's kind of three different
ways we can define this so if you're
taking notes this is the time to pick up
your pen there are three ways to define
these I'm going in increasing levels of
sophistication so I'm going to start
with the simplest one it's kind of just
intuitive it's the one that I'm pretty
sure most of you have in your brain when
you see these are two big lines that say
absolute value the absolute value of x
means take the positive value of X so if
X is already a positive number then the
absolute value of x is just that number
but if you have a negative in there like
say the absolute value of negative five
we mean well just make it positive right
tell me what the positive part of that
or the size of that number is
irrespective of what direction it's
facing whether it's positive or negative
okay we'll come back to this graphical
interpretation in a second because as
you know this is a graphing topic how
can we make this a little more technical
because this is a sort of it's a
colloquial definition if you like makes
sense but it's not very rigorous or a
more technical way of describing the
absolute value of X is that the absolute
value of X is the distance from X to
zero the distance from X to zero that
might mean the origin unlike a number
line so if I said to you before you know
this idea of the absolute value of
negative five it isn't just take the
positive value it's also a way of saying
how far is this number negative five how
far is it from zero the answer is it's
five away from zero just happens to be
in that direction but the absolute value
doesn't care all right so this makes it
excuse me more more technically accurate
but the most succinct way because
mathematicians are always looking for
sort of quick ways to write things the
most succinct way to write the
definition for the absolute value is
with algebra okay now you can see my
absolute value sign here I've left some
space above and below because what we do
is we say the absolute value is two
different things at two different times
if you've got a positive number in there
like five right if X is positive or if
it's zero for that matter then what is
the absolute value of X it's just X
absolute value of five is five provided
five is greater than zero which it is
right but if you have something which is
negative if X is less than zero then to
take the positive what we're really
doing is we're slapping a minus sign on
the front of there and the true
negatives cancel so the absolute value
of x is equal to minus X if X is
negative so if you come back to this
example that we had a look at before
I'll stay with the same color when we
say the absolute value of negative five
is five what we're really saying is oh
okay
the thing inside the absolute values it
fits this condition here if it's this
condition over here so therefore what
should I do
which which way should I define the
absolute value of X I'll use this part
of the definition so it's really
negative of negative five sure I said
which of course gives us the positive
five that we saw before
okay so these are all the ways that we
can define the absolute value they all
kind of fit together but what do they
mean visually because we're this topic
is all about graphing techniques right
well the graphical interpretation for
the intuitive definition over there on
the left hand side is basically if
there's any negative part of a graph
then you take that part and you make it
positive okay so in other words if
you've got a negative section you
reflect negative parts of the graph
across the x axis which is to say
upwards right so if something was
negative because it was down beneath the
x-axis we reflect it up above the x-axis
so we reflect negative parts above the
x-axis
so you'll see this this is kind of the
way that people see it most immediately
that you're like oh there's a part where
the graph just kind of rebounds off of
the x-axis so that's why this reflection
idea is pulled out and when we look over
the algebraic definition even though you
end up with the same result this algebra
tells us something very different what
it's basically saying is for different
domains so let me zoom out back there
again sorry with that for different
domains
the absolute value of x is defined by
different graphs so for different
domains we define the absolute value of
x with different functions altogether so
we have a technical name for this we
call the absolute value and other
functions like this we call it a
piecemeal function let me write that
word in in case you've never heard it
before a piecemeal function that means
for some parts of the domain some pieces
of the domain as it were we define the
absolute value in one way and there for
other parts of the domain we just define
it another way and you can see that
definition down here underneath the
algebraic definition so this is a
piecemeal function what that means is
sometimes it behaves like this other
times it behaves like that so why don't
we have a go at taking these definitions
and seeing what they look like let's do
as we did with our polynomials yesterday
let's do the basic graph and then let's
see ways that we can transform this and
look at different versions of it so if
you haven't already please go ahead and
draw up a set of axes if you're like
wait you shouldn't have scrolled past
that so fast you can't wipe off a
whiteboard that quickly
don't worry I'll come back to those
definitions in a second and of course
you get all these notes on canvas
afterwards so I'm sorry I should have
warned you that I was going to scroll
past that
all right the absolute value of x now
here's the way I'm going to recommend
that you think about this as a kind of
supplementary graph what I want to do is
graph this thing without absolute values
we're just gonna ignore the absolute
value signs graph that it's often you
say a very simple function that we're
beginning with and then we're going to
think about that intuitive definition
that we saw before mrs. Bowen is
everything ok I see you coming to the
screen everything's fine just make an
adjustment ok so what
and if you've got another color there
this will help but if you don't have
another color maybe you can do this in a
dotted line or something like that what
I'm gonna do is I'm gonna draw this
regular function without any absolute
value signs and then I'm gonna take this
guy and see how it changes it right so y
equals x this is our familiar straight
line that goes through the origin and it
has a gradient of 1
okay so there's y equals x and in fact I
may even write it like so all right now
let's use our intuitive definition it's
the easiest one to work with even if
it's not the most technically accurate
what I'm gonna do is I'm going to say
well are there any positive parts of
this graph if they're positive they're
fine they can just stay put because the
absolute value of a positive number is
just that same positive number and you
can see the part of the graph that
satisfies that condition right over
there in the first quadrant and the top
right hand side all of this stuff over
here is positive so absolute value of
this just ends up being that same graph
so I'm just going to go over that and
again if you are another color they're
just sort of reham ffice eyes that line
now for the left part of it this is
where we said oh you've got some
negative numbers here right I'm you
might have a set of coordinates like say
negative 1 comma negative 1 right it's
like well my Y value there is sorry my x
value there is negative so I need to
take the absolute value to get the Y
value that corresponds to it so it
reflects up I'm going to use another
color here it reflect up across the
x-axis and this happens for every single
point right if I took another point down
here like negative 2 comma 2 it would
reflect upwards across the x-axis and if
you fit these all together then
unsurprisingly let's sort of thread the
needle a little bit here you get this
rebounding thing that we were talking
about before right what you're looking
at here in blue is the absolute value of
x has an intercept there at 0 it sort of
turns around at the origin and this is
how we define the function ok now what
I'm going to do is recognize that we've
drawn this the the method in which we
drew it was to use the intuitive
definition but we can take let me just
scroll so zoom back out a second we can
take this algebra
a definition and what it tells us and
apply it to what we've drawn right let's
have a look at the way the algebraic
definition works there's the positive
part X is greater than zero look at the
domain that's the right-hand side over
here so this branch of the graph is y
equals x and it exists over here when X
is greater than zero or equal to zero as
well and then over here we have a whole
different branch which is it has a whole
different equation this is y equals
negative x so you can see I've got two
functions sort of coexisting together
they just like at that x equals zero
sort of tipping point they switch over
okay